vos propos étaient indignes et vous avez
été indigne vous avez été indigne parce
que qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer les yeux dans les yeux qu'il
n'y a pas plus de concentration de
population et de risques de transmission
du virus dans les transports en commun
dans les grandes surfaces qu'il peut y
en avoir
chez un coiffeur chez un cordonnier
c'est de la démagogie
vous avez été indigne des fonctions que
vous exercez je n'oublie pas que vous
avez menti vous avez menti monsieur le
ministre
ça n'est pas vous qui expliquiez au
départ lorsqu'il n'y avait pas de masque
par votre incurie vous nous expliquer
que les masques était pas nécessaire
inutile et peut-être contre productifs
est ce que ce n'est pas vous qui l'avez
dit est-ce que lorsqu'il n'y avait pas
de test vous avez expliqué que les tests
en marche et est totalement inutile
vous l'avez dit selon leur merci mais
c'est ce que ce n'est pas vous qui avez
dit au moment de la première piste
d'apprendre du premier confinement qu'il
fallait passer de 5000 lits d'aurea à
14500 liberia et au jamais vous êtes
vous bien ça mais lui et le président du
gym nosella jacob de la création de lits
ce n'est pas dans l'islam vous n'êtes
pas